Hi everyone, it's Jerry. The Rubinstein Trap
is a trap for white out of the Queen's Gambit
Declined. How it works exactly is to have
these three queenside pieces eventually converging
on the c7 square. Here's how it works. After
d4, d5, c4, e6...the Queen's Gambit Declined.
We have now what follows, a group of developing
moves... a group of logical moves for both
sides. Or in other words...minor pieces getting
out, getting castled, getting rooks to half-opened
files. So knight c3, knight f6. White pins
the knight, black breaks the pin. e3, black
castles, and after a couple knight moves we
have a very common position. One that could
come about from a different move order. And
before bishop d3 is played, the tension between
these two pawns is first resolved. So c takes
d, e takes d, and only then bishop d3. Rook
to e8, logical enough...half-opened file,
and white doing similar along the c-file.
Sensing pressure against the c7 pawn, c6 is
very common...ruling out any possibilities
for knight b5 to maybe converge on the c7
square, as well as just reinforcing the center
on d5. After now castles we have h6, throwing
a question to the bishop, and more long term
providing a flight square for the king even
though at the moment it is being guarded.
After bishop f4, the trap has been set. And
it's one that can very easily catch black,
the side who may very well be aware of this
idea of the bishop pair being very good in
a chess game. Or in other words, trying to
get a knight for bishop exchange. In this
instance here, it's faulty. Running after
this bishop pair in this case right here with
knight to h5, looking to get that dark-squared
bishop, runs into the tactic of knight takes
on d5. Knowing full well that if pawn takes
knight, bishop c7, the queen is dead. She
has no squares. Black can of course bail out
at this moment right here and not take the
knight. And instead knight takes f4, but note
that the knight can sidestep the pawn's threat,
and just recapture on f4. And after the smoke
has cleared, white is up a pawn, and a very
significant one at that being that it is a
central pawn, and white clearly stands better.